welcome to the reason Round Table your
weekly Refuge from the way people
normally talk about politics uh brought
to you by the magazine uh free minds and
free markets and whose editor and chief
definitely will not be featured in an
upcoming uh chart topping rap single I
am Matt Welch joined hopefully on video
as well uh by Nick Gillespie Peter
sudman and Katherine mangu Ward sup
y'all howdy hey Matt happy Monday so if
you thought that 2024 was going to be a
relaxing year I would like the name of
your doctor uh please uh and just
looking over the Drudge Report this
morning uh he went to the blood red
headlines which is always a good sign uh
and these were the big ones in all caps
uh drone Wars McConnell calls for
striking Iran and nuke warning so
welcome to uh this week uh three US
service members were killed and 34 were
injured in an attack inside Jordan on
Sunday and we'll talk about that a
little bit later in the program uh but
first um still more chaos and more
chaotic politics down at the southern
border with Mexico I will try to bullet
point as fast as I can in chronological
order the developments over the past
week beginning last Monday when the
supreme court ordered the state of Texas
by a 5 to4 vote uh to allow Federal
border agents access to the border with
Mexico presumably to cut some of the
razor wire that Governor Greg Abbott
down there has installed both in the Rio
Grand and near it um especially around
the Eagle Pass area 10 days prior to
that the Texas National Guard had
blocked border patrol Agents from
accessing the river when three migrants
were dying a mother and two kids and
there are two others uh who were in the
river at that same time time on
Wednesday Governor Abbott issued a
statement defying the Supreme Court's
order calling the large number of border
crossings and Invasion thereby
triggering a constitutional right to
State self-defense also on Wednesday
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
reportedly said in a GOP meeting that
the Republican attempt to attach a bunch
of border security items to a Ukraine
Aid Bill uh was now in limbo because
quote we don't want to do anything to
undermine Donald Trump on Thursday the
Republican Governors Association uh
issued a statement signed by 25 GOP
Governors standing in solidarity with
Abbott uh Donald Trump then encouraged
them to send their own National Guard
units down to the border to help out and
the hashtag Civil War began trending on
Twitter on Friday President Biden urged
passage of the Border Ukraine deal
saying quote it would give me as
president a new emergency author
authority to shut down the Border when
it becomes overwhelmed and if given that
Authority I would use it the day I
signed the bill into law and then on
Saturday the Oklahoma Republican party
condemned and censured the Republican
senator from Oklahoma James Langford for
working on that border Ukraine package
which they described as an open border
deal in a rally that day Donald Trump
said quote as the leader of our party
there is zero chance I will support this
horrible open borders betrayal of
America Katherine um do we need a
complete and total shutdown of
immigration politics until we can figure
out what's going on yes and if given
that power I will use it on the first
day that I have first hour yeah um I I
want to start actually with the um with
the senator lenford uh Oklahoma GOP
thing because it was to me it was just
such a fantastic microcosm of the whole
thing um in particular okay so again
remember this this man's crime is just
like
talking with people about a bipartisan
deal like like he was just like
doing legislating um which is his job
and you know it's we wouldn't want
Congress to do that it's no God forbid
God forbid Congress should do the the
stuff that Congress is supposed to do so
in the resolution uh condemning and
censoring him uh sorry censoring his
open border deal um this language was in
there and I just want to like have us
sit with the language whereas
authorizing several thousand people to
invade our borders before any action can
be taken is contrary to the oath that
Senator Lanford took to the
Constitution what does it mean
authorizing people to invade our borders
like that's a
nonsensical concept like there's this
attempt to draw a bright line between
legal and illegal immigrants um this has
always been kind of dubious especially
around Asylum Seekers and several other
categories of immigrants who can come
without prior authorization under our
laws already um the idea that we are
going to end up in a a sort of standoff
between National Guard and um and
federal border officers is uh very very
very troubling and this Oklahoma thing
just seems
so silly and sort of so internally
incoherent um that I I kind of want to
use it like as a I don't know like a
microcosm for this whole conversation
like it's it's just people making up
reasons for their side to have the
backing of the Constitution and like
this resolution isn't going to get us in
or out of it let's Steelman our Oklahoma
friends for a second here Katherine
which is to say that thousands number is
a thing that exists in the deal or at
least is our understanding of it that if
there are more than
5,000 um uh illegal border crossing then
that will be the numerical trigger for
or doing some kind of total uh shutdown
of the border so um you know it's a
transitive property argument but it's uh
but it's certainly um they're tethering
something to a thousand's language in
the bill right well I think it's just
the idea of the authorization of an
invasion like it's the it's the use of
the invasion language it's you know we
can we can you know I don't authorize an
invasion of my home when I invite you
over for dinner like that's that's not
the right way to think about it and of
course can let people in of course we
can choose to let people in of course we
can choose to not let people in that's
the legitimate business of Congress to
figure that out Nick there are a lot of
Republicans our Oklahoma friends and a
lot of non-republican as well including
people running for president you're
you're Oklahoma friends man I'm I am
very friendly with all people um who are
they're basically making the
counterargument that uh it's ridiculous
to like hinge border enforcement or
Biden saying that that you know I will
you know do this enforcement on day one
of this bill being signed when the
president has broad latitude to enforce
immigration policy already do they have
a point uh the point that they have and
I think that increasingly people in the
country are are bothered by is the idea
that the border is chaotic and that we
don't have an immigration policy that's
working I mean you know I mean what
we're turning the United States into is
like a gigantic Who concert except
people trying to you know people trying
to get in and being stampeded because
they're hearing good music here what we
need
fundamentally is a better border
situation where there is more control of
where people come in and where they
don't the solution to that is not by
criminalizing more and more people and
laying more and more barbed wire it's by
expanding the number of places where
people can come in Legally and more
importantly and this is something that
the Biden Administration did pretty
successfully and it really need and then
cap their own success on it but we need
to be doing more parole in countries
where people are coming on mass where uh
people who want to come here legally
whether it's from Mexico or Honduras or
Ukraine excuse me or wherever go to the
embassies or the consulates in their
country and actually work to get
preapproved where they have people who
will bring them here and will sponsor
them uh typically the parole or
currently the parole ter for about two
years they come here they are prev
vetted and they are authorized to work
um doing that kind of stuff is going to
alleviate uh all kinds of problems on
the border but we need to I think
fundamentally dellink what's going on in
the border with larger immigration
policy which we have not done because at
least realistically since George Bush
got reelected and tried to do
comprehensive immigration reform we have
stopped talking about that and all of
the focuses on what's going on on the
border and as long as we're doing that
we're in trouble as a country Biden I
think is rightly in trouble because he
hasn't addressed this type of stuff
trying to do it now uh the Republicans
you know have made clear and this is
disturbing even if it's politically
astute everybody like every poll shows
more people are nervous about what's
going on in the Border because people
keep seem to keep coming not through
points of Entry but wherever that's
going to cause a lot of chos and you
know like CBS ugv poll um shows 75% of
people think there's a crisis or it's
very serious On the Border that's up you
know like 25 points from a couple months
before that you know something needs to
happen but it's not going to happen
through a political standoff like this
unfortunately Peter you're an astute uh
Watcher of Mitch McConnell what do you
make of his intervention his leaking I
presume uh last week and what does that
say about uh your your sense of whether
there's going to be a more likely or
less likely chance that we will see uh
that border security Bill and or Ukraine
funding come out of all of this I think
so much of what we are seeing is
election year posturing that's true of
the Oklahoma letter that um Katherine
referenced it's also true of what's
going on in Congress right now where
Congress was at least making some steps
towards a bipartisan immigration deal
not one that Libertarians would
necessarily support but they were at
least trying to do some legislating and
what Donald Trump has signaled to the
Republican party is he does not want
them to do that for fear that it might
work because the like he he what Donald
Trump wants is for there to be chaos at
the border so that he can run against
Joe Biden on Biden you're not
controlling the Border what McConnell
basically said last week was yeah we're
going to let Donald Trump do that now he
has walked that back since and said
actually we're going to try to proceed
with a deal but I do think that the way
that that news cycle played out uh makes
it pretty clear that Republicans are
very willing to let the Border chaos
continue because they view it as an
electoral advantage and it's really kind
of telling it's it's cynical and it's
gross and it's awful that the party that
is supposedly now in favor of border
control actually seems to be at least in
the short term at least for the rest of
202 4 basically uninterested in doing
any sort of uh real legislating on this
issue because they believe that it is uh
that it will be politically advantageous
to them in the presidential election
coming up in November if things are bad
at the border and people blame Joe Biden
for it and but it is important to note
that things are bad at the border and
they have continued to get bad it's you
know there's no question the Republicans
here are awful at the national level
probably at the state level but there is
you know we there is something that
needs to be changed um and that's not
happening at all that's true and this is
a bipartisan failure and both parties
have played politics here I mean the
Democratic position seems to be we want
some sort of strict border laws to be in
place and also not to do any real
legislating or ever enforce those laws
that's not a tenable position but the
Republican position is chaos is good for
Donald Trump and therefore we should
probably let that chaos persist at least
as long as Joe Biden president so that
we can pin it on him Katherine um
speaking of untenability uh K Alex nasta
who is an immigration liberalized uh had
a pretty good Twitter thread over the
weekend um contextualizing all of this
stuff and uh even in the middle of that
he had this following thing that caught
my eye quote the Immigration Court
backlog is currently about 3.3 million
those migrants are going to be waiting
working and living in the United States
for for a long time and many won't leave
even if the court orders them to go end
quote that's just crazy untenable isn't
it I mean not just as a as a kind of
practical thing but uh certainly as a
political thing yeah I mean Alex is
basically always right about everything
with respect to immigration I I
associate myself with him I can't think
of a time that he's been wrong so um I
think that you know his persistent
efforts to point out what the status quo
really is um are really important like
they're here they're already here and
and that's again why I think this
Invasion language is so weird and so
unhelpful it's it's not it's not like
this isn't a Mars attack situation it's
not a Mars attack situation and uh you
know the Martians are already among us I
guess and it's fine um it's more like
Alien Nation which was
itself extended sci-fi parable about
immigration assimilation great movie
with Mandy kenin so as with actual
aliens when when they come we would be
better off to welcome them to talk with
them to have them uh you know to treat
them with respect uh to not have them
risk their lives to come here uh I can't
I can't speak to how the actual Alien
Invasion is going to go but we already
know what happens when we let people in
and uh you know when we let people in in
a as you know Nick is correct to not
that the is a mess but one solution
which I know is not on the table right
now in our current political climate but
like one solution one way to prevent a a
messy deadly confusing politically
polarizing playable disaster at the
border is to just let people come here
to just make the doors of legal entry
like to throw them open wider and it
doesn't mean we have to let every single
person come here although I think maybe
that would still be the way honestly but
the vast majority of people who don't
have communicable diseases don't have
criminal hist take your asist and leave
like I like I just think in the end uh
if if we are looking for a solution to
This truly horrible situation both at
the border and all these people who are
living within the country who are being
told at any time you know maybe your
status will be revoked maybe you will
have to be thrown out maybe you'll have
to choose between staying where your
life is and going into hiding or going
back to a place that you left for a
reason um I I just think that we could
just choose more openness that is really
an option and I think the only morally
defensible one but I also think a really
pragmatic one I I genuinely think that
this is doable um and Alex as usual has
like some excellent concrete steps that
we could take including stuff like you
know getting the you simplifying and
speeding up the the paperwork backlog
for people who are already here one of
the points that Alex makes in that post
that is very good is that this is is a
demand issue and this is a demand side
issue because the US economy is in some
ways especially with regards to the job
market actually doing pretty well um and
right and like there are there are a lot
of job openings especially for lower
skilled labor and so people want to come
here and so to me the the operating
metaphor here is not um movies from the
1990s about um alien detectives or um
alien invasions instead it's prohibition
and and people resist this for when it
comes to immigration because they see it
as something fundamentally different but
it's really this it's really very
similar in so many ways because there is
a demand for something um with
prohibition it was alcohol uh with
immigration it is good jobs and a better
life for your family and that demand is
not going to go away just because you
try to put an artificial barrier in in
the way of it right instead people are
going to try um they're going to try to
get it through means that are more
dangerous and more chaotic and it's
going to create a secondary Market in
violence and criminality that is what
happened in prohibition and it's what
what is happening with the border and if
you want to Tamp down on crime and if
you want to uh make it harder for uh for
for people for gang members and violent
people to come in uh to cross the border
then what we need to do is we need to
say people who are obviously peaceful
and just want to come here and work and
contribute to the economy they can come
in and there's an easy and
straightforward process for them to do
that and then we're going to focus our
efforts on catching the actual bad guys
who want to come over here and do bad
stuff it'd be nice to hear a president
you know who has the bully pulpit really
come out and say exactly that That We're
a nation of immigrants uh and that
everybody who wants to live and work
peacefully is welcome here it does cause
disruption we're going to meter it out
so it's not you know like a billion
people coming in the first year or
anything like that but we're going to
expedite it right now as much as
anything and this is true not just of
immigration but it's true of Economics
it's true of foreign policy we don't
have a national meta Narrative of like
what is America about and as a result
you start to see uh people knock off
things uh Force Republicans to say that
they don't want anybody new in the
country because things are perfect the
way they are Force left-wingers to admit
that we cannot admit people and you know
that not that this happens but it's the
fear you can't just bring in a lot of
people who are immediately going to go
on welfare roles which by the way if we
continue with current Asylum policy if
you bring people in and they can't work
that's like up beyond belief let
people come here and live and work
openly and honestly they don't get
welfare they don't necessarily get
citizenship but they do get legal status
and they're going to move into the parts
of the country where there are
opportunity and that will take care of
all sorts of problems rather than cause
any but we we need to be talking about
why immigration is important to the
country not just in economic terms uh
but also in kind of national and
identity terms and we also need to talk
about the the fears that people have
where you know part of this is a larger
anxiety that's throughout the country in
all different ways about the future
about how things are shifting radically
out of the world that most of us grew up
in and didn't like when we had it we
wanted it to change but now we look back
nostalgically as if you know the 197
when immigration was very low is somehow
a good thing I mean fashion yes it was a
great thing the 19 it's pretty good in
music under represented yeah uh prog
rock and bell bottoms bring him back
Matt likes the colors elephant elephant
bottoms bell bottoms H elephant bottoms
not enough all right as mentioned at the
top Iranian back militias killed three
US troops wounded 34 others in a drone
strike on a military Outpost in Jordan
uh on on Sunday President Joe Biden
tweeted firmly in response have no doubt
we will hold all those responsible to
account at a time and in a manner of our
choosing Republican Hawks who apparently
still exist as long as lindsy Graham
draws breath on this Earth uh called for
bombing Iran uh Peter you don't like
World War excuse me Matt he said hit
Iran now hit them hard yeah that's a
that's a right
sayl is signaling to grinder something
deep in his subconscious that's I don't
know what you're doing Mr Gillespie but
I like it Peter you Jo Biden also
finishes every policy pronouncement by
saying oh and I like ice cream I like
ice cream uh the time and place of our
own choosing I like ice cream come on
man uh Peter uh you're scared about
World War I all the time uh how is a
reluctant imperialist supposed to react
when Iran keeps proxy Waring us all the
damn time yeah it's a it's a tough
question I I think one of the things
that is interesting or that is worth
thinking about here is uh according to
reports this morning the US intelligence
military um apparatus is doesn't still
doesn't think that Iran actually wants
to start a larger war and that I think
is is pretty important because if Iran
wants to start a larger war with us then
they're probably going to be able to do
it
right like if they just want to go ahead
and say we're doing the big war we're
doing it now it's happening whether you
whether or not you like it then that's
going to happen and so what we want to
do is have a is uh design some sort of
response that is not going to trigger
that is not going to change that it's
not going to trigger a desire to start a
larger War that's not going to make them
feel like well we're backed into a
corner and it's a big war no matter what
uh so that's what we want to do and I
think the Republican bellicosity on this
issue is so telling and so frustrating
because they're not thinking about the
consequences they're not thinking about
the downside risk of attacking inside
Iran which is what a bunch of Republican
sitting members of Congress and the
Senate are are saying right now um you
know it's not just Lindsey Graham it's
John cornin Target Teran was his tweet
uh Senate minority leader Mitch
McConnell to go back to him right uh
serious crippling costs to Iran not only
on Frontline terrorist but on their
Iranian sponsors blah blah blah this
sort of thing right and it
is it is a posture
of of of aggression without regard to
the possibility that we could end up in
a war that costs a lot more American
lives and I just think that people
continue to underrate that yes it's
satisfying and even necessary to hit
back when somebody kills some of your
soldiers you can't let you can't let
that go completely unresponded to at the
same time you have to consider like what
are the what's the possibility that this
could break out into something much
larger with a regional power that has
the capability of killing an awful lot
of people even if we are probably
stronger than them in the long run why
are we in Syria why do we have troops in
Syria uh and what authorizes troops to
be in Syria and Iraq at this point that
is a foundational question and it's
weird you know the Republicans aren't
asking that question now but they will
you know when it becomes politically
advantageous but you know this is the
problem with having troops scattered all
over the place the reason you know what
Iran is doing in the region is trying to
destabilize any kind of either you know
actual Accords or growing Accords
between places like Israel and UAE and
Israel and Saudi Arabia America
shouldn't have troops there America if
they want Regional stability it would
have been nice not to have spent a
couple of decades destroying Iraq which
was the uh you know the regional uh
opponent and Nemesis of Iran and held
them in check obviously all we did was
destroy that country so that Iran can
have a a bigger hand but we should be
spending all of our diplomatic efforts
right now trying to build up a regional
Coalition of countries that all
hate Iran uh which they do because
everything that's happening in Syria is
because Iran wants it um I think that's
a more foundational question and
Republicans need to be held accountable
for being terrible when it comes to
foreign policy they almost always have
the wrong Instinct except when
occasional outliers in their party say
hey you know what we should be involved
in fewer places militarily than more
much of the Republicans response here is
as with the Border issue just an attempt
to capitalize on election year politics
here they're trying to make Joe Biden
look weak I think they're trying to play
into oh he's old he's daughtering he's
you know one of these peaceloving weak
Democrats
it's we can't have the hippies in
charge like you know he's not the worst
but he's you know yeah what I mean it's
it's not all it isn't all just that the
Republican you know the Republicans keep
taking advantage of how shitty Joe Biden
is it's like we need to I mean this is
the problem right from a Libertarian
perspective you know the Republicans and
the Democrats aren't offering anything
but you know we should nobody should be
uh you know when you're beating the
drums for war in the Middle East uh
nobody should take you seriously and
especially if you are part of a
government and an Administration and
certainly people like Lindsey Graham and
John Corin and Mitch McConnell they have
they are absolutely Central to 20 years
of God awful foreign policy as is Joe
Biden um so yeah the question isn't
whether we are weak or strong it's
whether we are prudent uh Katherine
you're prudent I heard you uh attempting
to talk what we going to say uh yeah I
mean uh I just wanted to throw one more
quote in there which was Tom Cotton my
personal favorite hate figure um calling
Joe Biden a coward Unworthy of being
commanderin-chief unless he brings
devastating military retaliation against
Iran's terrorist forces both in Iran and
across the Middle East this is you know
that piece of it is just largely the
electioneering of it all right like hey
I'm trying to I'm trying to put an a in
the American people's minds of what Joe
Biden is he's a coward and there it is
um but I I think the flip side of this
and you know Tom Cotton is is certainly
um he you know he certainly partakes in
this ideology which is that
um courage and like you know danger and
War are opportunities for virtue I mean
this is I do think if we're I don't know
if we're steel Manning but like there is
this belief on the part of some of the
less stupid Republicans that um maybe
War would be good for this country maybe
war is what we need maybe we are being
cowards and having our little our little
groups of Americans here and there um
you know when Nick says well why are we
there why are we in all these places at
least one answer to that question is
like we are looking for opportunities to
bravely Crusade for justice around the
world and we're going to take them when
they come and maybe this is it now I
think that's wrong I think that's
spectacularly wrongheaded one CL that
it's spectacularly wrongheaded is Tom
Cotton believes it um but I you know I I
think that there is it's sort of the
same thing that we're talking about at
the border like people are looking for
an opportunity for a single simple
concept that we can use to make sense of
a chaotic situation and maybe a big war
with a big enemy is what we need I think
that that idea is powerful In fairness
to Tom Cotton he has been very
consistent about wanting to to uh uh
overthrow the government in Iran since
even before he was in the Senate 100%
he's not dumb he's just super super
wrong he's not inconsistent he's not
hypocritical he's just wrong all right
we're going to get to our listener email
of the week uh here in a moment but
first the world would be a better Freer
and happier place if constitutional
protections for private property were
taken more seriously that's why our good
friends over at The Institute for
justice have released a new season of
their legal History Podcast Bound by
oath Bound by oath tells the story of
how the Supreme Court has cleared the
way for government officials to abuse
property rights to trespass on private
land without a warrant to restrict
peaceful and productive uses of property
to seize and keep property without
sufficient justification and many more
outrages featuring interviews not only
with Scholars and litigators but also
with the real life people behind some of
the Supreme Court's most momentous
property rights decisions the new season
explores the history behind today's
civil rights battles please do look up
Bound by oath wherever you get your
podcasts that's Bound by oath Institute
for justice i j property rights do it
all today you'll be glad you did all
right reminder email your Snappy queries
to Roundtable reason.com this one comes
from Christian who writes in part High
Roundtable Monday's discussion about
Javier Malay got me thinking are
Libertarians too obsessed with economic
growth as we all know growing the
economy means that there is in theory
more prosperity to be shared with more
people this is great and
everything but shouldn't we also
recognize that growing the economy
sometimes comes at a cost we know that
biodiversity is increasingly under
threat a million animals and plants are
threatened with Extinction some of them
within decades is the current trajectory
sustainable if not shouldn't we temper
our enthusiasm for economic growth and
make the case for growing more
sustainably after all if economic growth
is the one and only ultimate goal what
is stopping us from tearing down
rainforests what is the point of trying
to preserve the commons such as wildlife
habitats why bother building so many
parks and recreational areas when we can
build more of the profitable stuff in my
view Libertarians should be better at
recognizing that some things in life
transcend the economic sphere Katherine
how do you
plead I plead uh I guess guilty um I
think I am obsessed with economic growth
I think uh there almost is no such thing
as being too obsessed with economic
growth and I think it's because a um
complete understanding of growth
contains all of these things that the
letter writer wants us to think about
and cherish and protect that it turns
out that when people are wealthier and
have more choices that they choose to do
all this stuff they choose to protect
biodiversity they choose to make Parks
they choose to uh make room for Stuff
Beyond kind of straight up conventional
profitable activity um and conversely
that slightly slowing down I mean you
know this is the sort of reasonable
position right it's like hey you know
GDP ain't everything like we could just
we could just let it go you know just
maybe half a percent we could just slow
it down a little um and we could have
all these other things in exchange I
think first of all that exchange is
often a false one and second even
slowing down growth a little has massive
massive consequences in the long term
this is just the kind of compound
interest theory of things um that a
little less growth now is is
unconscionably less for future
generations and um you know I also think
that many of the problems that he's
describing uh they are they are
consequences of growth but I think that
more more growth also holds the
solutions like I I don't think just
because something was caused cused by a
phase of Economic Development means the
answer is less economic development
sometimes it's still more so more growth
forever and ever amen uh Nick how do you
plead I uh would uh point the reader to
various articles by Ron Bailey the first
off talk about how the species
Extinction uh estimates are almost all
wildly overstated um so if the origin of
this question comes from an empirical
fact we should go back to that and be
more uh cautious about what we're saying
there but beyond that to to agree with
what Katherine is talking about you know
economic growth does not mean
environmental despoil by any stretch
just as wealthy countries start to uh
preserve their Heritage the minute that
they get to a point where they actually
can have Nostalgia for the past rather
than running screaming from it uh you
know in in the environmental world this
happens too there's an environmental
kets curve once you reach a certain
certain level of GDP you start taking
care of the planet in a much better way
think about uh you know the the example
that always used to come up was East
Germany and West Germany West Germany
was a productive country uh West Germany
took much better care of its natural
resources than East Germany because they
could afford to and with that higher
level of economic growth uh comes a
higher interest in and demand for
environmental preservation these things
are not mutually exclusive in any way
shape or form and really just to
underscore Katherine's point you know
when economic growth isn't something
that you can fine-tune it's not you know
it it's not some kind of little you know
uh measure that you can change you
either have it or you don't um and uh
you know if we think we can take it down
from 3% to 2% which would be awful and
is kind of what we've been doing are
taking it down from 2% to 1% you don't
want to live in that world it's going to
end up being poorer and dirty year Peter
you're from Florida hasn't the the Mania
for growth ruined the Everglades or
something surprise it's an Everglades
question I I don't know I've heard
there's still a bunch of cool alligators
or something there is hovercrafts if you
want to take the tour I've never done it
um no the uh look the what Katherine and
Nick said is TR is right that wealthier
societies are on average much better for
the environment you see this throughout
history when you compare say uh First
World um you know dem democracies versus
communist countries or more
authoritarian countries a 100 years ago
but also you see this today where
wealthier societies are just have per
capita much lower emissions than than uh
other societies but let's let's table
that for a second let's say that I'm
like a little bit convinced by this
readers point that maybe there are some
trade-offs that are worth making we are
right now making too many tradeoffs
against growth and I will I will take
this point much better at the point that
we have some sort of budget for those
tradeoffs because right now what happens
is everybody makes their case well you
know we got to save the the you know the
three-footed toucan from the whatever or
something and like so that means we
can't build this thing here okay fine
the three-footed toucan we're going to
that's going to be our cause for here
but then over here we also got to save
the 74t salamander that like there's
only 12 of these left and right and okay
we're not going to build anything there
all right like at some point you have to
make a a a decision about how much
growth you are willing to trade off and
if you look at all of the federal
agencies Each of which has hundreds or
thousands or tens of thousands of pages
of rules the vast majority of those
rules are growth tradeoff rules and no
one has thought about them in a sort of
holistic budgetary way in the context of
all the other rules they just say well
this rule is worth it it costs us $100
million a year it costs us a billion
dollars a year in economic activity and
and we need to be thinking about this in
that holistic contextual way before we
can start saying well we're going to say
okay every now and then we'll make some
trade-offs against uh that that are that
limit growth we're not doing that and so
until we get there then I'm going to be
Pro growth all the way I would only add
that the uh you know if we postulate
that the um more or less uh elimination
of extreme Global poverty over the last
30 years is the single most important
and underrated uh news story uh one of
the uh underrated news stories as well
is that richer countries have been now
for the past 10 15 years um uh doing
less carbon emissions getting cleaner um
reforesting not deforesting um uh and
Etc um I can't speak specifically to um
biodiversity um but uh there is a
cleanliness the waters are cleaner the
air is cleaner um with all these rich
countries that's where the trend line is
going and if you get to a certain level
of richness um it starts to go if you're
going from from poor to industrializing
as China and India have been doing um
while eliminating extreme poverty uh yes
you are going to add a lot of net uh
carbon and pollutants in the air and
then people will start to get rich
enough to be able to demand like hey I
don't want to breath this um so um
something to think about this is all a
perfectly good uh transition into our
next topic um which is this on Friday
President Joseph Robin at Biden the
second third I forget second uh issued a
uh temporary pause he likes ice cream I
do air quotes now that people can see in
theory if we release this as video
temporary pause on liquefied natural gas
export terminal product projects at
least until the department of energy can
update the underlying analyses for
authorizations uh Biden says he's making
this move because and this is a real
quote while Maga Republicans willfully
deny the urgency of the climate crisis
condemning the American people to a
dangerous future my Administration will
not be complacent end quote we live in a
stupid country uh sorry did I say that
out loud uh this election year move
comes as American oil production led by
fracking and natural gas extraction has
reached all-time highs helping drive
down the price of gas which the White
House has claimed total credit for
citing its environmental policies uh
Peter I just want to ask the process
question on this doesn't this seem like
real bad process yeah it's a bad process
and like typical bad process um it's the
same bad process that we do for all
major climate related projects and
energy projects it's also the same bad
process that got us where we are at the
border like if you just temporarily say
this seems bad I'll get back to you
about
everything then you're it's going to be
a me of course it's going to be a mess
of course we're not going to invest in
the right things of course we're not
going to have peace and and order at the
border like like this is it's the worst
process and it's the process we're using
for everything also it's an election
your political stunt designed to
to appease a key Biden constituency in
particular the funded climate activists
and so when I say climate activists here
I don't mean people who actually like
manage Woods you know I don't mean
people who are like like quite involved
with is you know uh with the land and
with animals I mean the people who work
for foundations that do stuff in
Washington DC I mean PE groups like
climate Defiance and I named climate
Defiance because the White House named
climate Defiance in their brag sheet
that they published on the white
house.com under the what they are saying
leaders praise Biden Harris
Administration pause on pending decision
of liquefied natural gas exports and so
they published the good job note from
this group climate Defiance which
tweeted this out they were very proud of
themselves and then they're like who are
we you don't know who we are but we're
climate Defiance and they defined
themselves we are a radical Collective
of young people working to topple the
fossil fuel industry we've blockaded the
White House Correspondence Dinner
stopped play at the Congressional
softball game and sent top presidential
advisers fleeing follow along right so
they're not even bragging about having
any real impact they're bragging about
being obnoxious and annoying and that's
the people that the Biden Administration
has set out to appease here I really
wish they had tried to glue themselves
to Congress at the softball game game
it's easier to pepp spray that would
have been nice uh there's also the role
of the tick tocker Alex Harris of
Colorado um you know who you know it's
like if we're doing government by Tik
Tock we deserve what happens uh you know
China wins this round Matt Welch um part
of the problem here is that the Biden
Administration then this goes back to
something Peter was talking about at
almost every level of economic activity
and this is one of the reasons why Biden
is a terrible president and why he has
terrible disapproval or or he has high
disapproval ratings and terrible
approval ratings that rank up there with
uh Trump uh at this stage in Trump's
presidency even before covid hit at
every level Biden is trying to squeeze
down economic activity if you talk to
people uh you know in uh in business
they talk about how mergers and
Acquisitions every opportunity that
Biden has to say no or to slow things
down or to make you shimmy through a
Tighter and Tighter hole to get out you
know out into Freedom or something like
that uh Biden is doing this it's it is a
bad way to run a country you you need
economic freedom uh and you know when
we're talking about something like
liquefied natural gas this is such a
great thing to be happening it's great
for the environment it's better than you
know it's better than old dirtier F
fuels it helps geopolitically because by
having multiple sources in different
parts of the world that are able to
offer up energy it means that places
like China and especially Russia in the
current moment or the Middle East can't
dictate geopolitics as easily this is
such a bad policy um and to the extent
that it rests on the uh you know the
stooped and limpid shoulders of gen Z
they've got a lot to answer for uh the
swap out of of dirty coal even Clean
Coal remember Clean Coal that would be
in every like uh State of the Union
Address we need more Clean Coal uh the
swap out uh via fracking of liquefied
natural gas uh has been the single
biggest factor in reducing carbon
emissions in this country so when the
brag sheet from the white house uh when
the statements from the president lead
with that's why we're serious about no
that's why you're unserious about any of
it we've known the stuff for 15 years
and you're still pulling this in
election years uh as a cave to you know
these groups who actually they also need
editors in this group Peter with that
long list of things that they've done
they could have just shortened like we
are period like just like get
straight to the point here people
they're your favorite type of people
right the the bridge blockers yeah Matt
loves a bridge blocker I mean it's also
though like why why are we why are we
soliciting blurbs on our policies like
that's another question is like this is
not like a new novel and we're like oh
let's get some other popular novelist to
like say a nice thing about it and stick
on Peter Travers quote yeah not this is
not the way unless half Stars they're
just they're just saying the quiet part
loud just like we are doing this to
appeal to young people in an election
year thank you goodbye all right we're g
do lightning round quick uh can't let it
pass that last week there was a New
Hampshire primary
very exciting uh in the Republican side
Donald Trump won 54% to 43% for Nikki
Haley despite the presence of a whole
lot of Independence voting for that and
more Democrats than usual and the
Democratic primary because it's open uh
and the Democratic side Joe Biden got
64% who was not on the ballot Dean
Phillips who was got 20 Maryann
Williamson got four I think verman
Supreme came in like fifth not quite
fourth that I was hoping for uh on the
Democratic side uh at any rate or maybe
he was in the Republican side I don't
even remember anymore um uh let's go
quickly one takeaway each beginning with
Katherine Nikki Haley is out there
raising a ton of money right now and I
I'm just trying to figure out what she's
going to do with it right I mean I know
I know that she thinks she's still
running but as far as I can
tell nobody else does except for the
people who are giving her millions of
dollars so it's confusing to me um I
will say the folks that are on the you
know axio had a report of her kind of
fundraising the folks that are on the
list of you know Republicans who are
giving Nicki Haley money they tend to be
on the serer side of the Republican
donor class and and I I get that they're
just still
hoping that this is a fallback plan a
safety option you know something will
happen and and she will be viable um
doesn't look like that to me so that's a
total endorsement of all policies um
backed by Nikki Haley's donor be clear
that analysis that I just offered is no
I get ready y'all get ready for me on
this podcast for the next several months
like I'm holding off today cuz like we
got we had like Foreign Wars to talk
about my none of the above Animal
Spirits could have never been at a
higher Mark like none of the above none
of these people never just say no I'm
gonna be the Nancy Reagan of politicians
from now on W I don't know what RFK Jr
did to you Catherine um he's out there
Fighting For Freedom uh nick uh one
quick takeway on the New Hampshire
primary uh you know Trump is the
Republican nominee Biden is the
Democratic nominee and the country at
large hates both of
them the country at large and me
specifically it is amazing but in polls
in po I mean this is like you know we
thought 2016 was going to be the worst
and it's like it could always get worse
uh Peter you know after the ship crashes
in Aliens and Bill Paxton is just having
like a lot of feelings and he's just
like That's it man game over game over
man that's my take away from New
Hampshire I'm since we do visualness now
I can just what uh what did that say man
that said that said when hell was in
session it's the uh the Memoir of
Jeremiah Denton Jr a uh P Vietnam P guy
Stockdale among other people um so let's
get to our end of podcast what we have
been consuming in the cultural Arena
I'll I'll let Nick continue trying to
invent something so Katherine why don't
you go
first
so I rolled up here ready to say that I
this is what I consumed and now I'm
feeling embarrassed but I'm just going
to say it anyway I reread Plato's
Symposium this weekend I did guys that's
what I did and I think that's probably
afterward did you take the Play-Doh and
you make like a little like a stick
figure out of it play it was play to
Playdoh Symposium Barber Shop yes so uh
it was for a variety of reasons but I
reread it in part because
um like like cable was out it C that
cable was out yeah as if I've had cable
for years like who has cable
um anyway uh I reread it in part because
I heard uh a song from uh hewig and the
Angry Inch which is a whole song about
the idea of love
presented in uh one of the speeches in
the Symposium and I was like that sounds
bananas cuz it's this whole theory about
how like people were two halves and they
were torn aunder and before that they
were like spherical monsters that rolled
around challenging the gods anyway I
wanted to check if I remembered that
that was actually true and um I'm here
to just tell you that Plato Symposium is
pretty funny and you should consider
rereading it it's also very very short
but uh I think uh in retrospect my
answer about like um Republicans seeking
virtue in war is probably because I just
spent a little too much time with the
Greeks this weekend and so I apologize
to everyone Plato Symposium it's pretty
good also hewick and the Angry Inch it's
pretty good I just uh that's what I read
That's what I'm consuming okay if you
can be like I looked at a baseball then
I can say this uh Peter what did you
consume so I've been watching clips from
Steven solder step solder BG's really
fascinating
2014 experimental recut of Raiders of
the Lost Arc the great movie that
launched the Indiana Jones uh franchise
back in the early 1980s and Soderberg
just made two changes to this movie the
first was that he removed all of the
sound and replaced it with Trent Reser's
social network soundtrack so it's now
got this kind of like creepy uh
electronic dark vibe to it and then he
also took all the color out of the movie
and and transformed it into a black and
white film and he did this he says in a
little essay that he wrote on his
website as a as an experiment so that
you could just focus on the staging of
the movie and this is something that
really struck me when I saw Raiders of
the Lost AR on the big screen last year
for the first time was how expertly this
movie is staged and I mean every one of
the shots is composed almost
like almost like a a sort of perfect
little bit from a a stage musical or a
stage production where you've got a
whole bunch of people and they're all
lined up perfectly and everything is
kind of surrounding the central
character uh you have all of these
fantastic Silhouettes throughout the
movie I mean it starts with one of the
most iconic Silhouettes ever put on film
that shot of Indiana um you know sort of
in uh where you just see the outlines of
him with his jacket and his hat and you
think about that silhouette and all of
the elements all of the sort of creative
decisions that went into getting that
shot it's not just oh Steven Spielberg
sort of wakes up on the morning they're
going to shoot the opening of the movie
and it's like yeah I guess we'll we'll
shoot it like this it's it's also the
costuming department it's the stance
which with which uh Harrison Ford is you
know moving through the shot right and
sort of holding himself in his body it's
the whip it's the Hat it's all right
it's also Douglas slom and his
absolutely incredible photography I mean
just uh just so Artful and so cinematic
and what this what this soberg cut does
is it puts all of the all of the staging
decisions all of the editing decisions
all of the visual language of the movie
into sharp relief it allows you to focus
on it better without thinking so much
about the story and you see just how
beautiful the film is how uh how iconic
all of these shots are but also you also
see how easy it is to just follow all of
the action it is just a amazing
especially in the sort of uh you know
the the the late years of shaky cam um
here where that that is that's kind of
dying in cinema I mean I think John Wick
has has helped kill off that tendency
but where you can where you can just
follow no matter how fast the cuts are
moving you can follow every single bit
of the action and you always know
exactly where every character and object
is in relationship to every other
character and object and it's such a
great little lesson in the craft of
Cinema and how good Steven Spielberg was
at it 40 years ago uh in one of the
great popular movies ever made uh Nick I
know that the late years of shaky cam is
going to be your next erotic Memoir uh
what have you uh uh you know I'm also
looking forward to the era of uh shaky
viewers so like you know as long as
we're shaking the camera can be still
that's right uh what did you consume
nick uh well you know uh over the
weekend like Peter I consumed some
Cinema uh I was in a hotel and I ended
up watching a couple of Hallmark movies
which I highly highly recommend are we
okay did you watch them entirely in
black and white with a 9 in Nails
soundtrack yeah of course I only see
them black and white anyway you know I
don't know what happened uh but uh and
uh paging Mr Darcy things like that what
I I highly recommend checking out the
Hallmark Channel whenever you get the
chance stay for five minutes uh what I
read uh this past week is a uh new book
by a UC Santa Cruz historian named
Benjamin Breen it's called tripping on
Utopia Margaret me the Cold War and the
troubled birth of psychedelic science
and it's an attempt to recast how
psychedelics um kind of entered into the
American mainstream or it's somewhere
between the mainstream and the avangard
in the 50s and instead of focusing on
people like Timothy Larry and Richard
Albert ROM Doss and what not it it
starts the clock a little bit earlier
and talks about Margaret me and her uh
one-time husband the uh sociologist and
kind of uh gadfly intellectual Gregory
Bateson and the way that they actually
uh helped bring a certain strain of
thinking related to psychedelics uh and
particularly LSD and therapy in the
1950s and early 60s um and also how they
were deeply uh implicated in Cold War
attempts through uh the CIA as well as
the department of Defense to use these
drugs in ways that were kind of
nefarious in a broader sense excuse me
if you're interested in the history of
post-war intellectual uh and Commercial
developments this ties into a number of
critiques and Analysis that point it uh
point to the way that defense spending
really underwrote a massive amount of
Silicon Valley development in
California's economy certainly a lot of
the things that made America the country
of the future but also culturally uh in
terms of things like encounter magazine
and a wide variety of different cultural
activities that places like the CIA
underwrote um so it's it's very
interesting in that way if you're
interested in psychedelic history this
is an absolute mustre the other thing as
I was reading this and if you're a
reason reader who remembers the 90 one
thing that I've noticed because the
author um comes back to or he sides on
the question of like these things need
to be kind of gatekeeper and regulated
in various ways and we would probably
disagree exactly what that means if I
was talking to him but I've noticed many
of the arguments that we thought were
kind of absolutely one in the 90s and
this includes things like well you know
immigration more immigration is better
than less immigration more free trade is
better than less free trade more
individual choice in the Technologies of
living uh and Technologies of the self
that we we use are better um those are
being attacked or rethought and
reformulated and so you know hyek
somewhere and I'll mangle it said you
know that every generation needs to
recast the arguments for freedom in new
and Urgent terms and it's you know
fascinating to me to see how many things
that seem to have been one many
intellectual and cultural arguments in
the in the '90s are actually coming back
where people are saying you know what
maybe individuals can't handle the range
of choice and the depth of choice they
have whether we're talking about social
media or uh you know literature and
culture or drugs um so I recommend
reading tripping on Utopia marget read
the Cold War and the troubled birth of
psychedelic science but also uh reading
it critically while the Hallmark Channel
is blaring in your hotel room oh yeah
that uncritically uh the H Channel no
well you know what when you see John ra
uh kind of work uh it helps you
understand why artistic forms are better
or
worse uh pursuing to that last uh point
about uh individual freedom and stuff I
just saw uh that referenced on Twitter a
new poll showing that uh comparing um uh
people who graduated like kather ringu
Ward from uh uh uh Ivy League schools uh
answer to the question of do you think
America has too much freed
compared to non um I League school grads
and it's amazing it's like 54% yep too
much Freedom here at Old Ronda sh the
link yeah for that I'm sure it's uh I'm
sure it's a top top quality public
policy research uh my what you have been
uh consuming uh last week uh Melanie the
uh singer songwriter shant Tu on Janu
from the late 60s and early 70s who
performed at Woodstock you might uh
remember her for the uh semi novelty hit
single Brand New Key oh man she had a
pair of brand new roller skates and you
had the brand new key uh there was no
suggest of material uh or subtext there
um anyway she died after uh leading a
rich and interesting life I went down as
one does uh the rabbit holes of
Wikipedia and of spotify and listen too
bun her stuff I was fortunate enough to
have a friend who uh covered idios
syncratic Melanie uh songs over the
years including uh is she as pretty as
me which is one of the weirdest songs
you'll ever hear um but this all led me
uh to um I reled me let's say to Miley
Cyrus's backyard sessions which she did
I think most of it was during covid um
uh because because you could still like
go backyard back then and it was the
lockdowns uh she had really nice big
microphone and some good musicians and
they did a lot of really great mostly
covers
of things and she does a cover uh duet
with Melanie um who was still alive back
then and was still in fantastic voice uh
just grally but elastic and big and
strong and weird and uh and Miley Cyrus
who's a a phenomenal singer I think and
and a very generous uh artist uh like
honoring those who went before she's
very much like Dave GR in that respect
um it's a really terrific cover of look
what they've done to my song ma uh which
is great weird little song uh from
Melody so if you're starting down your
Melanie journey I would begin with the
Miley Cyrus backyard sessions mashup
with Melanie and then uh go forth after
that and fun fact about Melanie she
described herself as a Libertarian um as
uh Jesse Walker was pointing out that
she was one of those people who would
show up on those kind of seist
celebrities who said that they're a
Libertarian uh very interesting
background uh interesting person to uh
go and and learn things about um uh and
that's the end of that tune uh we are
now wrapping up this podcast the reason
round table thank you for listening to
it uh we have a lot of events uh over
time but I understand Katherine that uh
this coming weekend reason is uh taking
a pretty active role at Liberty Con in
Washington DC do you wish to speak to
that we sure are there are going to be
quite a few reason staffers
participating in um students for
Liberties annual conference Liberty con
and um full disclosure I am on the board
of students for Liberty cuz I think it's
a really cool organization that helps uh
bring the freedom to the youths and help
the youths bring the freedom to the
world um I guess not the IV League
youths who think that everyone has too
much freedom but um more like the um
like the the youths in Argentina let's
say um the conference is pretty fun and
uh I think it will feature Nick
interviewing Justin Amash I've got of
panel Stephanie Slade's going to be
talking about the Game of Thrones uh
there's just like a whole bunch of stuff
going on so um if you are in DC or if
you can be in DC and you want to come I
think there are still tickets and um
it's a good time other events that we
are having in the future can be found at
reason.com events are there podcasts at
reason.com podcast Katherine do our
newsletters now get catched at
reason.com newsletters I hope we do have
if you go to reason.com newsletters you
can sign up for quite a few newsletters
we've got some new ones we've got an
Elizabeth Nolan Brown newsletter on sex
and Tech we've got a Robbie Suave
newsletter on the media and censorship
and stuff and stuff we of course have
Christian bridy's newsletter on uh
housing zoning Urban policy and the like
plus our OG's the reason Roundup uh and
uh reason daily reason alerts all kinds
of good stuff um we can be very much up
in your inbox should you desire it so
language reason.com newletter sign up
for what you want literally an invasion
of your inbox yeah like if you sign up
for a newsletter is that an invasion of
your inbox I guess so um all right well
be careful out there uh and we will
catch you next week
[Music]
goodbye